finlandia tiene que tomar una decisión
histórica el país escandinavo que
tradicionalmente se ha posicionado como
militarmente no alineado debe elegir a
mediados de año si solicita o no el
ingreso al otan los expertos afirman que
la invasión rusa ucrania ha acelerado el
proceso con la solicitud de adhesión
como una conclusión inevitable de reglas
del teide de rafa ahora se dan cuenta de
que no conocían a rusia de que rusia es
agresiva imprevisible y violenta y
necesitan una nueva solución de política
de seguridad los recientes
acontecimientos en ucrania parecen haber
cambiado la posición de helsinki con un
aumento del 40% en el gasto militar que
un nuevo deseo de utilizar a la otan
como un amortiguador de protección es un
cambio que ha provocado respuestas
airadas de moscú como se vio a finales
de febrero buscando hasta instituto dijo
straw es evidente que la incorporación
de finlandia y suecia a la otan que es
ante todo un bloque militar tendría
graves consecuencias esto requeriría
medidas de represalia por parte de
nuestro país
más extraño sí a pesar de las amenazas
finlandia decide presentar su solicitud
su posible integración aún tardará algún
tiempo probablemente varios meses
mientras tanto el éxito de cualquier
solicitud depende del acuerdo unánime de
todos los estados miembros de la otan